you can't say we et aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur le tant attendu god
simulator donc simulateur de chèvre oui
oui l'ont fait oui ok donc on peut
courir n'est soit l'échec je veux casser
cette palissade tu veux te lécher
je vais juste les chebec après la police
pour casser des portes et vous n'avez
pas le gros truc ça mais juste cette
chère elle fait ça tape fort
l'autre jour j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
indoors donc ça c'est pour taper est-ce
qu'on peut pas prendre ces matches est
bon ce n'est pas toi alejo du jeu beach
ôônous fait une danse
j'aime bien me replacer le coup un peu
contre le mur hp aurait trop voir le
côté du bus au plus tard pékin aux
obèses est ce qu'elle peut je veux
rentrer des laissez moi vivre à voilà on
pense à ce que je pense arrête de mettre
la tête dans les murs [ __ ] ah voilà
c'est comme ça pour prendre les choses
avec sa langue n'est pas un et pas des
gens au banquet où elle a pas un petit
problème avec ses pieds elle aussi vous
dire est qu'elles essaient de s'enfuir
mais y'a pas n'ya pas le seul sous ses
pieds
je suis ce chiffre très discrète ne voit
jamais
as voyages non monsieur
est ce qu'il est possédée à tu passeras
travers ce mur 1 et tout est parti de
son corps ne sont absolument pas mis
dans le bon ordre et sympa d'être tous
vos tableaux dont j'aimerais bien voir
ça chez moi perso attention l'évasion à
la james bond au
what paf
j'en étais sûr allez je vole au nez mois
avec vous lui aussi regarder leurs
doigts de pieds bruit pour ça aidez moi
[ __ ] vous pensé à ce que je pense
non mais c'est vrai quoi c'est
scandaleux quoi c c'est vraiment c'est
n'importe quoi c'est est ce que tu crois
que tu es vraiment caché là à la justice
tel alors oui enfin c'est fermé pas très
longtemps pour 7 qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
passer l'aspirateur
je suis la chèvre allons donc là haut tu
montes avec nous tout est en fait le
corps parle à la tête ça lui faire comme
les chats je vais me frotter à ses
jambes tu veux t'en ferula tu cherches
tu as à faire explique moi
je t'aimais jen a là aucune réaction
l'autre contre ses bourreaux meilleur
avis on va faire du trampoline ensemble
tu alors on cherche toi quand tu as peur
tu te caches les yeux en fait était
morte
si tu te pointes la tête dans les
marches mais pas pour aller loin ça
suffit maintenant
[Musique]
tu es prêt à faire le grand saut
meilleur ami tu allais et votre
livraison est arrivée madame à presse
comment j'ai pu vivre dans ce petit
souci
donc je crois que je rentre dans une
maison dans laquelle tu n'es pas
supposée entrer toi toi avec ton bracke
a réussi à passer un leila ya un truc à
faire
je veux jouer avec vous moi si je veux
danser moi aussi j'aime appeler fait
c'était ma manière de danser je peux pas
m'accrocher la voiture ok alors lui
savait crasse pas mon parcours j'ai pas
de problème
or
oh merde les mecs je peux avoir des cas
là sur le ventre du tout d'accord aucune
chaîne n'a pas demandé leurs collègues
sont tout était très bien mais non mais
c'est sérieux c'est bien on va se mettre
debout sur la boule mais tiens voilà
scoliose au bond à moi j'ai changé de
chèvre on va voir ce que ça donne
pourquoi vous montrer ça à wendel
regardez ce coup eux pèchent en moutons
ah oui laissez moi encore danse avec
vous s'il vous plaît yeah yeah yeah
cette chèvre a un pouvoir incroyable la
chèvre des bons c'est bien chez aulas il
a voulu me faire un câlin 20,6 et
capirossi
[Musique]
attendez la station service et faudrait
s'en bat les couilles
ah non moi on m'a dit de tenir la
question laquelle ça notre chèvres peut
manger
est-ce qu'on peut manger une autre
chèvre what's up et attention regardons
résultat si génial et pourquoi ils
partent en volant la crise qui si les
développeurs de gold simuler jo away put
alors concentration allait elle ici cob
ben voilà on sait désormais que le jour
où tu brûles il faut juste plaquée
contre un mur ou là à travers un bureau
de préférence et se rasseoir pour
travailler pour la sieste du midi les
conseillers a adopté cette position un
très bonne pour le dos aux mondieux on
ne caressent enfin aujourd'hui la chèvre
jetpack aller
oui tu t'envoles up non c'est pas ce que
je vais faire
hop je t'embarque
qu'est-ce qui arrête ça tu veux pas
juste t'accrocher avaloq s'orienter
[ __ ] c'est pas possible c'est trop
demander un brett bien mec là y'a un
autre mec là mais non mais fallait pas
toucher dès maintenant il ya un mec en
parapente on va essayer de le de faucher
[Musique]
je suis déçu je suis déçu h et sur faut
rentrer par ce trou l'avait quand vous
voulez faire
ah oui oui oui mon gars allez direction
cet entrepôt et voilà les gens aux
termites sur ce [ __ ] de troy g8 10
minutes à rentrer dans studio pour que
vous alliez petite motivation et
j'espère que ça vous aura plu je
rentrais peut-être une vidéo sur ce jeu
puisqu'il est quand même vraiment fun et
je pense qu'il me reste pas mal de trucs
à explorer on se retrouve dimanche soir
dans une nouvelle vidéo chat au monde 10
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]